now for the real reason I'm here I'm
going to see what makes an angle on
curry so different to anything I've ever
tasted before as I've been gifted the
venison mr. Han Lee is gonna create a
curry using the ball that he slaughtered
see normally we'd cook this separately
it's very rustic tell me nothing's
pelleted nothing's ever off a bird and
what's that that's putting there my
father is putting another kind of live
which we find the force and what's it
like thank you that's quite citrasena
yeah yeah that's like lavender we use
even the fruits for black pepper
everything mr. honey is using in his
dish comes from his own land this is the
first Indian curry I've seen made
without any dried spices what's that
then with the chilies
he's roasted we have better flavoring if
we roast it on the ash like that yeah it
gives a better sense yeah well we got we
do the same with peppers and the most
surprising ingredient is something I've
never seen before
it's bamboo shoot' yeah that's a
fascinating smell and you know that it's
like a spicy edge to it while the pork
and the bamboo curry cooks I'm gonna try
out these Nagaland ingredients with my
saddle of venison to see what I can come
up with pure Phillip
just a little touch they intrigue me the
flavor there you know
[Music]
how'd you turn up the gas thank you how
many Westerners have come and cook in
this kitchen no no I'm the first
hmm it's a division in Scotland wheels
ever swing age oh yes it means
our passion is joined to the dish while
my venison curry reduces mr. Han Lee's
pork and bamboo curry is already done
and I can't wait to taste it
the pork is delicious very tasty the
chimney the garlic and it looked quite
sort of boring and greasing the flavour
wife delicious
that's delicious the pork the villagers
from today's hunt that didn't get a cut
of the deer came to share mine there's
real community spirit here and it makes
eating together all that more enjoyable
the pork dish I tasted of theirs was
amazing you'd think that there was 15
different spices the dried bamboo in
terms of flavor its intense yet has an
intriguing sort of turnip stroke
cardamon sort of slightly spicy edge to
it who would ever believe we're in India
no spice turmeric yeah no coriander no
cinnamon their clothes
everything's just yeah from the ground
it's quite interesting you dive into
their world and you get rid of that
monkey on your back and all of a sudden
you start to relax in a big way and
forget anything outside this village
I came in search of India's best-kept
culinary secrets and Nagaland didn't
disappoint I've had my first taste of
his regions in digits ingredients and I
can't wait to see what other surprises
the North East has in store thank you
it's made feel so special
best wishes thinking without take care I
was an on words
[Music]
and I've taken a bit of nagaland with me
I want to use the bamboo shoot' on my
food store when I get back to Calcutta
extraordinary different and incredibly
rustic very humble very simple but
fascinating food Oh totally unspoiled
and in a way in nothing India